here's the here's where I'm at it's on
let's do it and then we got pregnant
right away I think I'm married and then
yeah
and you have four yeah you can do more I
don't know six I don't know a four is
enough well five like I don't know five
I could do five but also like how many
boys how many girl or woman needs a
break yeah really
he's amazing yeah um I don't know how
she does it
I really don't it's a girl boy girl girl
girl
so three girls and a boy huh yeah yeah
and it's is it I mean cuz I talked to
Sebastian the other day about his baby
and it's life-altering they love it well
you love it oh yeah well I mean it's why
it's you leaves me why you want kids I
know why he wants he wants kids he
doesn't want to take care of them shut
the [ __ ] up okay I literally a minute so
I'm listen I I hate talking about kids
for people who don't have them because I
know but I did you end up like waxing
poetic about like how amazing and
life-changing you don't really know who
yeah kid yeah and then I hear he doesn't
know people don't have kids like [ __ ]
you yeah yeah dude like my life is good
like I feel like people some people
should have kids some people shouldn't I
just I've known that I wanted them for a
long time and I just all right here's a
story so good when I went with my wife
gave birth to my daughter leading up to
it I was like I knew I wanted it I
wanted to have children with this woman
so badly
it was so excited but then there's also
like alright I'm gonna have to change a
diaper I'm gonna have to you know get up
in the middle of the night the second I
met my daughter I went oh my god you
like you were who I've been missing like
I've been like that know that no wonder
I had like little moments of depression
like no wonder I sad when I was a kid
like I had to wait 33 years to meet you
it was like instantaneous
so then all that like I need to [ __ ]
went away and it was like I just wanted
to I will say though also literally this
morning I was in the park and I was
working out and this guy came up that's
his life he lives in a [ __ ] rom-com
right the life that you leave I know
it's only gonna sound more rom-com until
I get to the punchline okay but I had a
football there and this guy this guy
this walking was had a baby in a
stroller my letterman jacket brown
that's great and he was he did baby in a
stroller and he was like hey do you want
to throw I was like yeah dude the stroke
so we had a catch and I was like how old
your baby and he's like four months and
I was like oh wow I think you are in it
but congratulations he's like yeah
thanks and I said I got I got for myself
and he goes wow that sucks
[Laughter]
he was so sleep-deprived
yeah I know exactly where he is like cuz
that's what happens yeah and the thought
of four kids to this poor man was like
no [ __ ] it just came out of his mouth
I don't think he meant to say it yeah it
wasn't judgmental I was like wow that's
[ __ ] deal with four of these little
[ __ ] yeah and so I actually wrote
something in it on Instagram today that
like yeah it their time like it's
[ __ ] sucks sometimes like you're
woken up constantly you're constantly
worried pain you feel more deeply than
before you worry about the world in a
way you didn't before the environment
yeah the environment the world anger you
suck I can't watch [ __ ] Game of
Thrones I can't watch people get their
heads chopped off yeah you never seen
Game of Thrones no I watched the first
episode I'm like nope push a kid out the
window my wife and I are like okay next
don't go to strangers house so but I
will say I mean I it's so worth it on
like a deeper level that you really
can't convey to somebody who doesn't
have kids no you did that's all no you
know no you actually did you actually
thank you you actually did and I get it
whatever you're saying I get it now we
live in a regret it's legal our lives
could have changed no [ __ ] why'd you
make me do that if you're not ready
you're not ready you know it had nothing
to do with not wanting them it was
circumstantial I wasn't well she was
alive all right well yeah I listen you
get no judgment for me much yeah
although my goal is to make everybody
here feel worse I just want to make
everybody
[Music]